to set the scene of Hannibal's rise and
to understand the world around him we
have to understand the origins of the
geopolitical conflict that dominated his
world
on the one side we have Carthage
a great Port City an heir to the ancient
Phoenician Legacy of seafaring and trade
by the 5th Century BCE it was an
important power with colonies and client
states across North Africa Spain and the
Western Mediterranean
opposing her was Rome a city-state that
had rapidly conquered the Italian
Peninsula and was ready to LEAP beyond
the confines of Italy these two great
States would by the 3rd Century BCE find
themselves eyeing each other warily over
control of the whole Central
Mediterranean their rivalry would
culminate in the Punic Wars which
spanned more than a century
and the entirety of Hannibal's life now
despite this enmity that happened later
Carthage in Rome enjoyed many centuries
of peace
from the 6th to the 3rd Century BCE as
the Mediterranean world became ever more
closely linked through trade and
exchange
cities like Rome and Carthage were often
Allied and had both grown wealthy from
long periods of peaceful interaction
yet it was an unstable world with great
Empires and cities rising and falling
and large migrations of people perhaps
the most destabilizing event was the
rise and death of Alexander the Great
who almost a century before Hannibal's
birth had remade the map of the known
world
consequences would soon be felt in the
Western Mediterranean and Carthage was
drawn into new conflicts as it sought
like many of her neighbors to protect
and expand her Holdings
archaeological discoveries of sunken
ships
scattered along the floor of the
Mediterranean Coast provide evidence of
a big jump in the sheer number of
vessels sailing the sea mostly for trade
but there was also an expansion in the
number and the size of Warships in this
period
the typical warship of this era was
driven by three Banks of oars
these were each manned by separate
oarsmen now this type of vessel is well
known it's known as a trirem and it
acted as the primary warship in the
Mediterranean that was Intel quadraremes
took their place in the 4th century
these new ships as described by
Aristotle were actually a carthaginian
Innovation quadraremes had two
compartments of oars that were manned by
two people per or so just imagine how
that shifted the power and the speed of
the vessels
these quadraremes were Then followed by
quinquirimes it's still open to debate
exactly how these quinquirimes operated
but the general understanding is that
they had either two or three separate
compartments for ores and they were
operated by five people on each side
these ships and their successors were
initially the flagships for Naval
commanders in the mid-third century
according to polybius quinquirimes were
considered the new standard warship for
the carthaginian Navy but this may be an
exaggeration
ancient sources tell us of even bigger
ships than fives
called hexaremes and septaremes sixes
and sevens in this period they thrived
as well
so a naval arms race was taking place in
the Mediterranean and Carthage in Rome
were soon swept up in it
Alexander the Great didn't just spark a
naval arms race
he also created a role model for
generations of military and political
leaders
many sought to embody the same style of
heroic and aggressive leadership it's
certain that Hannibal like almost all
boys of status at the time would have
been brought up on Tales of Alexander's
exploits what young boy wouldn't be
captivated by his exotic conquests in
Far Away lands
one such boy was Paris who grew up to
become the king of the Greek state of
epirus about 50 years before Hannibal's
birth and he epitomized the warrior
ruler of this era a brilliant military
mind Paris embarked on a series of
campaigns around Greece and Macedon and
the Eastern Mediterranean
but Paris soon came West
he was called to Aid the city-states of
Magna Gracia in southern Italy who were
soon to be faced with an increasingly
powerful Roman Republic that was
threatening their independence Paris may
have seen an opportunity to carve for
himself an Italian Empire and he landed
on the peninsula with a great Army
sparking what would be known as the
pyrrhic wars and these lasted from 280
to 275 BCE
now Paris was one of the greatest
generals of the era
he rarely was defeated in the field and
for a time he rested control over
southern Italy from the Romans he then
turned his sights on Sicily following
entries from another Greek city-state
Syracuse to come and help them Drive the
carthaginians and their allies from the
west of the island
finding common cause in a mutual enemy
Roman Carthage in fact engaged in a
strategic Alliance to jointly face this
threat at this moment
in Sicily Pierce was successful in
almost every battle encounter he had yet
years of warfare attrition and
unpopularity amongst his new subjects
took their toll and Pierce could no
longer hold on to what he had gained he
retreated to epirus in 275 BC
now instead of celebrating the defeat of
paris's comrades in arms the Roman
historian Cassius Dio knows that in the
chaos Left Behind Roman Carthage began
to see each other not as allies
but his Rivals for Primacy over Sicily
Paris is even alleged to have noted on
his departure
what a battlefield we're leaving for the
carthaginians and the Romans
as the great General predicted War would
indeed flare up between Rome and
Carthage just nine years after his
departure
the conflict that broke out is known
today as the first Punic War
and it endured for 23 years
it was so epic in scale that it
drastically reshaped the balance of
geopolitical power in the central
Mediterranean
Hannibal would be born into the final
years of this war and understanding it
is key to understanding his career and
the carthaginian mindset into which he
was born
it's certain that Rome and Carthage
never plan to engage in a war of such
magnitude when it all kicked off in 264
BCE
it's often compared to World War One
where none of the major Powers could
have imagined how far-reaching its
ramifications would be
polybius the main source for the history
of the first Punic War noted and I'm
quoting we shall find that never before
in the history of the world have two
such immense forces been ranged against
one another at Sea now this is certainly
hyperbolic
as the world in this case is really just
the island of Sicily and the central
Mediterranean which was the principal
theater of the war
and the prize the two ties two sides
were fighting for
remember that controlling Sicily meant
control of the whole Central
Mediterranean Zone and the shipping
lanes east and west across the sea
so the complexity of the situation on
the ground is best told by the incident
that sparked the outbreak of the war in
the Strategic port city of masana which
is today's Messina in the northeast
corner of Sicily
the faction left in control there by
Puris was a group of mercenaries called
the mamortines
they were facing an army-headed by
Syracuse Now Syracuse was a powerful
independent city-state on the island who
wanted these mercenaries out
so the mammortines hedged their bets by
seeking protection from both Carthage
and Rome
Carthage arrived first being close by on
their base of lipora in the aeolian
islands but then the mamortines who were
of companion extraction decided to shift
to Rome when that city later decided to
send assistance to
snubbed and not willing to accept Roman
influence over this key port so close to
lipara
the carthaginians responded by a lying
with the syracusans
and war broke out
we have copies of pre-existing treaties
between Rome and Carthage that
acknowledge that Sicily fell within
carthaginian sphere of influence
but the Romans decided to come to the
aid of the mammortines and crossed from
Italy to give their support anyway
doing so not only gave Rome exposure to
battle off the Italian soil but it also
served as a pivotal moment for its
growing Imperial aims
polybius saw the significance and he
begins his history of the period with
these words
I shall take as the starting point of
this book the first occasion on which
the Romans crossed the sea from Italy
[Music]